uh thank you. Maybe we can get started.
Uh first of all, thank you so much for
uh coming for the workshop especially
ones who didn't get the seat. Uh I I
promise you I'll do my best to make it
entertaining especially for you who are
studying. Uh thank you so much.
>> Yeah. Uh actually it it makes sense. So
now I know like why the tickets got sold
out, right? Uh which workshop actually
sold out the tickets.
So uh let's start with uh my
introduction. So I'm Raj. Uh I work as a
staff software engineer uh at IKEA.
uh I work for a domain called
deliverance services. Uh basically we
are like almost more than 100 engineers
and six pedex teams altogether. It's
like a mini company within the company
itself. Uh I'm very interested with
architecture, neuroscience and
linguistics and now AI. So if anyone has
some cool projects because everybody is
building cool projects these days,
please find me after this meeting.
So quick pulse check uh with the uh
audience. Uh who is visiting London for
the first time?
Okay, cool. Welcome to London. Uh who is
here uh from the engineering background
also with white coding and prototyping?
>> No, all of okay. So uh who actively uses
agents like co-pilot?
Okay, this is going to be tough for me
then.
So extensions.
Okay. So everybody's pro. Okay. Fine.
>> Not so much as I want.
>> Okay. So much tension now. Uh
so you're going to sit here in this hot
room for more than an hour. So first I
will uh give a bit of introduction of
what I'm going to present today. Uh it's
basically on agent and the context
management. Uh I I divided into three
parts. One is the situation which all of
you already know. So I'll keep it tight
and short like five minutes. Uh then
I'll talk about the problem. This is
where I'll spend a bit more time on the
slides because I think like uh nobody is
actually seriously looking into the
problem. Uh and I want to bring it up
then less slides and more into some kind
of a hands-on uh how the uh actual
demand driven context actually works.
All good.
Okay. So, let's start with the first
one. How many have seen this movie?
Momento.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. Cool. So, I I'll give
the gist of the movie. So, this guy is
very skilled uh very talented. The only
problem he has is uh he can't hold
memory more than 15 minutes. So every 15
minutes he has to take his notebook uh
watch his tattoos that he put it on his
one and figure out okay what I was doing
before the 15 minutes and he does it
again and again. If you relate to the AI
and AA agents things and all it actually
fits exactly how the movie is and how
the agents are right now. If you go and
watch this movie you don't need to watch
YouTube or blogs to understand agents
and MCP. This movie actually tells you
about everything literally. uh and as
this guy has a memory problem uh in the
same way the AI uh that we got
introduced couple of years ago uh is
very good with reasoning computation uh
code generation it's it's benchmark as
like uh above the par the only problem
is the institutional knowledge right the
domain knowledge that you have that's
that's the only thing we have to be uh a
bit problematic
so from AI to agent if you look at the
uh evolution uh it exploded So it
started from prompt engineering first of
all uh then there was rags uh now MCPS
then multi- aent now it is deep agents
uh I recently found out like uh using
replet actually you can build a full
stack app in 10 minutes that means the
by the time you make the instant noodles
you already have a million dollar app
already working on your laptop so we we
got it to this point like it's
extraordinarily good
now That's AI and agents. So let's talk
about enterprise AI.
Okay. Uh I don't know how how many of
you have this question but most of the
enterprises I see the question is okay.
A is pretty smart. It's doing uh code
generation fullstack apps reviewing your
PRs uh doing incident management all
those things. Uh right. So if I is doing
that much why is the Jira tickets or
Apex are not moving on the dashboard
right? Why do I don't see the delivery
actually? So everybody is speaking about
look at like 3 minutes everything is
ready. Yeah. Okay fine. Why are my J
pics are not moving? Because that
defines the business delivery and that
defines the return of investment, right?
Uh and as you see like uh it's it's from
the Mckenzie this year like 80 8% of all
companies use AI but they only see like
uh 6% of value creation.
Okay. So I think this is the problem uh
that we have. Uh I have four Jira
tickets different ones uh sample ones
and you can see the green ones that I
have uh marked is basically which LLM is
or already trained on like API standards
or like uh things very they already know
it's a general knowledge right that's
fine those tasks from the ticket it can
pick up and it can do it now there are
second part orange ones which we have to
teach them actually so you have you know
this but do this in this way so all this
kind of an orange ular things will fit
into you know your agent extension like
skills or like uh
but the red ones that's what the
institutional knowledge is which sits
within the company and within the
people. So unless if it picks a task uh
if it picks a ticket it has to fulfill
all of them. It is so good with uh green
ones and orange ones but it struggles
with the red one with the institutional
knowledge and what I believe is uh right
now the coding agents are getting so so
better. I feel like if there is an AGI
coming the first AGI will be a coding
agent for sure. uh
so to fix the uh giving the
institutional knowledge to uh the agents
so we have an industry solution already
so this is basically your return of
investment on AI pipeline will look like
right so you have LLM model quality uh
you have agents and you have agent
harness and your institutional knowledge
sits under conflence jira sharepoint
gith GitHub all those things and
basically retrieval layer is what
industry is telling us will fix that
issue. So you build that retrieval layer
and then it will fetch all those things
and give it to an agent and agent should
be able to do it right. So basically uh
so 40% uh actu factual accuracy can be
achieved through rag or like knowledge
graphs actually uh but with a documented
uh knowledge base.
Now basically if you build a retrieval
layer it has to work right now let me
ask you a question. How many have you
built uh retrieval layer things like
rags and mcps? Okay, cool. All of them.
Okay, now the question is how many did
you build? How many MCPS did you build?
How many have you built more than 20 MCP
servers?
Okay. Okay. So, nobody beats my record
then. Uh so what I see is uh mostly in
the enterprise organizations and all
people are building like 10 to 15 or
like 20 MCP servers or like rags uh
knowledge graphs on top of their
institutional knowledge and to the agent
right so the assumption is if we if I
can build all those MCP servers and give
that agent I don't need to work anything
like it will do but the thing is when
you plugging this MCP servers basically
all this data coming out is mostly
undeterministic
it's unreliable and it's untested right
so especially in engineering nobody does
evals actually it's it's more like a
data machine learning concept but we
don't do eval so for me if you sorry uh
uh if you plug uh an MCP or like a rag
and all we see whether the output is
coming or not rather than is it really
valuable actually is it really solving
the problem or not. Uh that's the main
problem that I see. I'm not saying
pointing other people because I was that
person. I was like okay let me build all
MCP servers plug in my institutional
knowledge. I'm going to prove that point
that agents can semi-autonomously can
continue and fill those zero tickets and
finish it. Right? But every time when I
build those MCP servers 10% 20% 30% of
time it was accurate but rest of the
time I was doing the data enter job for
them actually. So I was filling the gaps
asking the questions. So basically I'm
doing more work than actually doing less
work. Uh so I think this is the main
problem and I I actually was in this
fourth stage where I literally started
to write the domain context with
handwritten actually. So okay let me
write everything and prove the point but
I got really exhausted of doing it.
Okay so how I don't know how many can
you relate uh with this pie chart uh but
most of the enterprise uh the
institutional knowledge is kind of
something like this. So 20% if you see
it's outdated, 20% it's unreliable. Uh
20% 10% is always duplicated with
different places. And the major problem
is 40% of the knowledge is always uh
tribal knowledge which means people know
how things work. So it's it's never
documented actually. So in this
situation of an enterprise and you build
like 100 MCP servers and plug into that
monolith, it doesn't matter how many you
build, it won't work because basically
your whole institutional knowledge is a
is a monolith. Uh I think like because
you're all from the engineering
background so you already know uh the
transformation of monolith legacy system
to microservices, right? So in the same
way unless we break down that monolith
knowledge base into some kind of a
context blocks which are useful for
agents then only we can actually make it
useful for them uh for the agents and
actually make them semi-autonomously can
actually do the tasks.
So that said uh we are going to talk in
this workshop mostly on that monolith
how to break it uh what is the approach
to break it and how it is useful uh when
once we break it and this is a job we
need to do because uh uh the LLM
providers will focus on the uh LLM model
quality the agents will focus on the
harness things and there is a big uh uh
retrieval market of 9 billion they're
focusing on retrieval but nobody is
going to come to your company and fix
your knowledge base. You have to fix it
yourself, right? So, how can we do it?
Uh,
okay. So, the demand-driven context uh
is what the as a solution I was trying
to propose, right? So, basically if I
have to give an abstract of it what it
is like we have my uh monolith
uh services and we have this process of
breaking them into microservices. We
have waterfall model which we
transformed into agile. In the same way
when you have a monolith of
institutional knowledge how do you
transform into a context blocks using an
approach. So this is an approach of how
we can do it.
Uh before starting uh just not an idea.
So uh we already tried with some data
sets and try to prove this approach
works and uh in the March we have
published a preprint uh uh in RXV. So if
anyone interested in reading academic
papers uh you can find it with the
demanddriven context or I can I can also
give you a link after the uh workshop.
Okay.
So how does it work actually uh
when we are giving institutional
knowledge to agents basically what we
are trying to do is we're trying to do a
push strategy right so we build
everything and we push it to uh to it.
So in in this approach it's more pull
approach which means for example let's
say a new joiny has joined your company
right how do you onboard a person so you
onboard them for a one two days you give
some initial orientation and then you
tell them like okay these are the
confluence links these are the github
this is the some some kind of a
documentation you have to follow things
and all then you just assign a task to
that person so but you're not going to
tell okay go and get graduated on on
this knowledge and come back then I will
give you work right so you'll just
assign the work item and when you assign
the work item the person will start
asking questions fill the gaps if the
person is very much into documentation
he will also fill the documentation for
you uh he gradually uh get his knowledge
of of the institutional knowledge right
in the same way we don't push all the
knowledge to the agent rather than we
start giving problems to agents like
work items and let them actually pull
the information from us
and once uh pull the information
also ask them to document it
uh in in a in a better way rather than
in a monolithic structure. So if you so
that's the four layers. So you have a
monolith uh a framework and it actually
pulls and actually creates a good better
context uh blocks you can actually
relate it to more into a legacy monolith
to microservices directly if you have to
have an knowledge of it. So this is how
it works.
So this is one cycle of uh how
a problem to an agent and the in the
first attempt the agent will fail to do
it. So it will say you know what you
gave me a problem but most of the uh
documentation I couldn't able to find
anything I couldn't able to do it then
these are the things I need to do to
finish this task and it gives a
checklist of things so we fulfill the
checklist like we fulfill this checklist
so once it is uh given the problem is
solved it will take that knowledge and
also it will update that means curate
the knowledge in a particular place so
that it can reuse or like other agents
can also reuse. This is one cycle. So
the idea is if we can do it in multiple
uh sessions with multiple problems. So
it will gradually uh curate your
knowledge monolithic knowledge base uh
and also document it for you.
Uh you can also relate it to TDD. So how
many are uh do TDD or like nobody hates
TDD right before I uh Yeah.
>> Okay. Okay. So, uh in in the same way,
right, in in a TDD approach, what we do,
we just write the failed test cases. We
don't build the product first of all. We
just write the failed test cases. Uh we
see what is the code that is missing uh
for the failed test case to pass and we
just give the code and we gradually
build the product based on the failed
test cases. In the same way we give
problems that agent will definitely fail
and we gradually uh fill those gaps and
at a certain point it becomes semi-
autonomous with a good uh institutional
knowledge already.
Okay.
So I think I can jump into uh some kind
of a demo already. Uh so I will use
terminal. So don't hate me. Uh I think
like all of you from engineering
background so I think like you'll like
terminal. Uh let me switch to terminal.
Okay.
Okay. So on the on the far left what uh
right what you see is how uh under the
hood it works actually. So when you have
given a problem uh how does the agent
will fail? How does it demand for the
knowledge uh that the problem has to be
solved and a human like a domain expert
and all uh fills those gaps and then it
will curate uh a new knowledge base for
you which is which is much better and
then the agent succeeds and you repeat
on the next problems. So that is how one
cycle uh things. So how I it can be
implemented? It can be implemented using
any agent. There is no uh it can be
implemented on cloud or copilot because
it's an approach you can uh do uh in any
way you want. At work I use copilot. Uh
so I implemented this using copilot. Uh
but because everybody I I believe loves
more cloud code. So uh I created this
demo with cloud code. Uh and you can see
it's just a combination of skills,
rules, uh agents and hooks and some kind
of a place to save the knowledge base.
On the middle pane, what you're seeing
on the top is your monolith basically.
Uh this is a representation of your
conflence, Slack, GitHub and all. But
just for a sake of demo, I just put some
flat files that look like them. Uh so
that is how your monolith uh knowledge
base will look like. On the down, what
you're seeing is on a live. So when it's
solving a problem how it is actually
adding the new knowledge uh to it. So
this is how uh it is. So, let me
So, what I'm going to do is I'm going to
go to an agent.
Okay, I'm going to basically give an
incident problem to do the root cause
analysis, right? So, okay, what I did is
you remember in the previous slide there
is a GT samples that I showed, right?
It's a combination of uh knowledge that
is documented, not documented things at
all. So, this incident also represent
the same kind of combination. So, there
is some knowledge that is documented
already on your monolith. some it is not
there or outdated or things like that
and most of it it doesn't couldn't
wouldn't able to find because it's never
written down actually so when I gave
this problem so it uses those skills
that I have developed using this
approach and it will try to actually
first go to your uh monolith actually on
the knowledge base and try to find
information on what is uh there so
think about it like this so
First part is retrieval. That means it's
already doing what RA and MCP is doing
first part. But what else it is doing is
after it fetches the data, what it will
do with the data actually. So that is a
missing part. For example, when you give
a new conference links to a new
employee, the employee goes there, looks
into it, but doesn't find information.
But it he doesn't stop there actually.
He continue asking questions. So to
solve the problem, then then just adding
more knowledge and things and all.
Right? Those are the next steps missing
right now. It's we just stop at
retrieval. So this is the next three
steps it does actually. So you can see
the confidence score is almost 1 to five
because it says
these are the particular terminologies.
I don't understand actually these
terminologies and these business logics
uh is not needed. So one thing you need
to look at here is whatever it has said
this is the undocumented information
that means it was never written down. So
unless you don't do this way you will
never know what is not documented. For
example if somebody says like okay there
is documentation missing we need to
write okay what do you want me to write
actually so there is so much in the
people's head I can't write so much
right somehow it has to surface. So when
you give a problem it actually surfaces
what is not documented and it tells me
okay this is missing I need to have a
new information there. Uh so what I will
do is so it does all the three steps. So
then what I will do is I already have a
pre-prepared answer
very high level prepare uh answer I gave
it to it uh of like what is the missing
information so okay this is the missing
information you asked me uh to solve
this problem can you solve this problem
now uh
I didn't expected this one
Uh notifications is yes. I'll just say
yes.
>> It asks also what fictional name should
I use.
>> Okay. I didn't see it. See when I did
the test run, it didn't ask me the
questions.
>> Let's see. It knows it is a demo.
>> I trained it to Okay.
No, it is already what it is doing is
already.
So you can see on the live it is already
adding the entities that uh the new
knowledge base has been come into the
place.
>> So the knowledge base uh manage as a
file system right as a system of files.
For the demo, I'm just showing it as a
file system, but it's basically your MCP
servers. Uh the data will stay in
conflence, slack or things. Uh you can
just plug in and use the same MCP
servers or rag and all. So it no need to
be a flat file.
>> You treat this as your persistence layer
for for this,
>> right?
>> It's like a me do you use any like a
memory tool for for this? Yeah, I will
show you on the next look like how I'm
going to see uh
okay so it started from 56 entities or
something with the uh this one right now
one problem actually surfaced six
entities that are never been documented
and when I gave that information to it
it is able to actually discover curate
another five or six uh new entities that
were never documented. So it does
discovery of the gaps. It also gets
information from me and also stores
information, new information and all.
Uh this is one. Okay. Next let's see
this is a busy window. I tried to
actually do things but uh it didn't
worked out. Okay. So what you are seeing
on the on the window is like 14
incidents. You have seen one problem
that I solved with an agent, right? The
communication. What if I took like 14
incidents uh and I just go and have 14
cycles of this thing and how it does? So
if you see on the left side it was the
first incident right. So right now it
has 1.5 confidence and everything is
critical every so basically nothing is
documented so everything is critical
high the data is missing. So I started
giving answers to on the first incident
then I repeated for the same second and
third and continuously for like 14
incidents but on the 14 incidents it
basically actually able to go to a
confidence level of 4.4 because first it
disco on every incident it got the list
of answers for me and also it documented
everything for me. So it gradually from
1.4 four to almost like five range of
knowledge uh it improved. uh so if you
look at the traditional way in
traditional way what we do is we solve
all the context problem right we have to
deal with it first then I have to give
it to agent in this one we are moving
agent from a consumer to a knowledge
manager so you just don't consume from
me I'm going to tell you but the whole
knowledge management is also your job
and you have to do it for
Okay, I think we can get back to the
slides a bit. Okay, so what we have seen
is uh we have I have run one cycle and
also I have shown how it look like when
I run in like 15 or 16 different cycles,
right?
But if you have want to do it manually,
it would be really painful because I
tried it after 15 cycles like nobody
would like to actually sit with an agent
and you know you have an incident but
you won't be sitt with your agent and
keep actually asking questions and
telling you about your problems right so
that is super painful. Uh so but the
thing is we can automate this process.
So this is where actually it's it's
really good and gets interesting. So
here is the thing
you all we already have all the work
items right we have Jira we have
incidents uh we have uh customer support
tickets like that all those kind of a
work items already there right sitting
in the archive so why can't we take uh
them and actually use the framework uh
and uh validate across your monolith
database run an automation and see
actually what is the state of your
actually right
Okay, let me see let me show you how it
looks like. So rather than actually
doing it manually at a scale if we do
this approach. So how does it look like?
So the demo that you're seeing is almost
like everything is preset. Uh
for example, I have the demo. I have
like a platform operations agent and uh
I'm saying okay these are the recent
incidents let's say I have 20 recent
past incidents I have uh like an MD file
or a JSON file right it has all the
details of description of it things and
all uh comments and everything and the
rest of the files are your knowledge
base so it's it's a file system but you
can also actually connect with the same
way the conflence and things and all
just for a demo purpose and just showing
it as a flat files now what I'm trying
to do is I'm going take all those
incidents and validate each incident
across my knowledge base and ask the
agent okay tell me uh how much of the
document is good how much of the
documentation is I can't trust it or
like old or outdated and how much is
actually missing not documented as per
this incident so let me
run it
okay it will take some time so it will
take three steps actually so one is uh
it generates probes which means a basic
test it will write to actually test your
knowledge. Then it will run those tests
and then analyze the gaps actually.
Okay.
It's a little bit hot in the room
actually.
I mean the apps it's just like a clever
problem I imagine.
Uh okay for example let's let's say you
have an instant call the notification
service is not sending uh customer uh
messages to
uh SMS service right so the notification
service then you mentioned that the
agent sees is there a documentation
related to notification service
>> so it doesn't find that means you never
wrote a documentation and notification
service I do understand what is a
customer SMSS and all the customer
notification service when you mention
it's a gap because it's never documented
or it takes a customer notification
service goes to conflence and sees like
the documentation how old it is. If it
is says like uh it's like one year old,
it will tell you look I looked into it.
It's like one year old. I don't know
whether I need to trust this
documentation or not or like incomplete
uh documentation. So if you see it
scored each incident it took it and it
looked at all the knowledge uh base that
you have connected and have a
consolidated list of like scoring of
like okay partially the agents can
handle uh the basic edge cases of the
incidents that you give uh because your
knowledge base is not complete and it
will show you how much of the tribal
knowledge is missing system information
business process what are actually are
missing from your uh uh institutional
knowledge when whatever is not
documented. Uh these are the probes
and it will also identify uh what is
critical and what is high. This is
really important because let's say there
is some kind of an example of
notification service which I mentioned
right it is repeatedly
uh appearing in like 20 occasions and
you don't have
this is the first that you need to fix
as per your documentation. So it will
also help us actually understand when
you're
uh breaking down your uh knowledge base
you need to understand what is critical
actually what I need to focus on first
what makes value for me
so organized into critical high medium
so this is what like uh I showed the
flat files but you can also connect it
to the various data sources that we
So the step one is basically what it
does demand extraction. That means every
incident it will extract uh the
checklist of information what is
missing.
On the second step is what it will
consolidate everything what is missing.
So it will create like systems and APS
and all and how many are clean, how many
are stale, which is incomplete, what is
entirely missing. Uh something is
tribal. uh those kind of a
classification it will also do
and it will create a kban board for you.
So what happens is so if you want to fix
your institutional knowledge base
basically you just just like Jira
tickets we finish it we actually has to
document these missing pieces and all
and the the moment you started to so it
also saves in the context lake so it
also has to build its own uh uh
knowledge base
and you can see the performance so once
you're fixing the sticks on the can uh
the knowledge.
So
that's how so what we've seen is one is
the approach first of all which means
not the pull push approach but the pull
approach how to do it one cycle or
multiple cycle how it look like but if
you put it in a scale of automation then
how much valuable it uh would
Okay. Now, uh uh the important question
is
>> sorry about this.
>> Double mic. Yeah, it's cutting out a
bit. So, I'm just going to put that one
on as well.
>> Should I do a voice over later?
Actually,
>> I think you need to repeat.
I have the patience who has the patience
for a second.
>> So the question is so I was all all the
time I was talking about okay it
receives the context so we give the
information it will store it but the
question is where does it actually store
it? So I have a very opinionated
opinion. Uh hear me out. Uh I prefer uh
it has to go to a GitHub repository. Uh
because eventually somebody will
actually come up with a you know 20
million seedfunded uh SAS solution for
you. Uh but before that I prefer uh to
actually put it in GitHub as a
repository. Why? Because if you look at
at a scale, if you want to do this,
there will be multiple agents, multiple
teams actually contributing to the same
knowledge base and there will be
conflicts and resolutions, right? So the
uh the easiest way to do is using GitHub
because it actually comes with inbuilt
uh uh PR processes uh review processes
things and all. So if multiple domain
expert are sitting and uploading the
files or like agents are contributing to
it the most efficient way to manage is
in a GitHub something like a structure
like this and the other advantage is
also if you put it on GitHub you can
also publish it to conference later or
like slack wherever you want to publish
it to another uh uh solution that you
want to use. uh so I prefer to have it
on GitHub but if you want to directly
integrate it to conflence and all you
can also insert do it.
Next is uh a meta model. Uh how many are
aware of the word meta model in the okay
maybe I can quickly show you how does it
look like.
So meta model is basically something
like this right. So and uh how does your
uh domain actually structured around
like uh is a business process or uh how
it is related to a systems how systems
are related to uh APIs and how is this
uh business jargon or like tech jarens
are actually linked to which one. So
these kind of a relationship uh meta
model is really important. It's not
necessary uh for the approach that I
have proposed but it's an add-on and why
uh you need to have this one is right
now think of it as like a map right now
your agents doesn't have any map
actually to navigate with your uh
knowledge base basically what you're
doing is you're dumping like uh these
many number of files and it need to
figure out which file I need to need
right but your file structure is
actually a representation of your meta
model it actually knows how to navigate
For example, let's say can you fix this
system? It will understand if I make
changes, which business processes will
be affected and which APIs I need to
change or like touch these kind of a
things. So, it's also important to have
a meta model. If you have it,
uh then it will produce more value. So,
I strongly prefer to have a meta model
along with this approach.
Okay.
So the last part uh is what is the value
it created. So
there's a lot of slides that you have
seen lot of demos that you've seen. So
personally I need to also share like
what is the value that I see when we uh
I was using it or like uh the other
people who I shared with already were
using it came back with the feed
feedback and told me uh first the most
valuable thing is
knowing the unknown. So what is never
documented is something can be surfaced
only by this approach actually. Uh
otherwise you'll just end up in u an
endless mroboard of like putting tickets
on okay this is missing this is missing
I need to add it I need to add it and uh
keep on doing it. So this is the fastest
and better way to discover uh with your
previous work items and all what is
never documented uh things and all. uh
second is uh basically I can now give
work to agents rather than I do all
those things like uh rather than I
become I give the agents all this
information let it manage my knowledge
management I don't want to be the
knowledge manager of it so let let it do
it so those are the two big values that
I have seen if you want to use it I
think like you will also see the those
two as the most valuable uh but these
are the other things what I seen
now. Okay. So, I also need to tell you
like what is the drawbacks of also using
it, right? First of all, if you are
coming from a small team or like if you
say like no no no my documentation, my
knowledge base is really good. I'm like
super happy for you. Uh you're the lucky
ones in this world right now with
agents. uh for you it might not be
really relevant unless you have a very
uh very complicated uh uh documentation
that you have uh second is I already
mentioned the manual manually doing is
it's very painful I don't prefer anyone
to do it if you want to just try it for
testing purposes you can also do it but
u automation is the most best way to
actually use this one
uh this is very early this approach so
by tomorrow warning on YouTube somebody
would have already posted something
differently uh better than me. So uh in
the in the uh era of AI nobody knows
like uh how long a thesis or an approach
or an app product going to survive. So
for now I see this is the best approach.
Okay. So the whole workshop so we
started with uh one pipeline right on
the ROI and so the demanddriven context
actually sits between this monolith and
also the retrieval layer actually and
what it does is uh it actually helps you
build curated context blocks for you.
You can also think of it like a cache
database that you have. So every time
you agent doesn't need to go and know
boil the ocean for fixing an issue
rather than if you have a good context
block of information most of the time
80% of the time that can be usable
because what I also believe is it's
always the 80/20% rule so 20% of your
documentation is most useful 80% is some
corner cases you have to look into it so
rather than giving 100% of things you
need to figure out what is my 20% of
that uh that is super helpful for agent
and have it like a cache database uh the
context block of it using it and rest of
it you can leave it like a links so
whenever agent feels I need more
information then only it can go and
check uh the whole monolithical uh
institution knowledge
okay so from here what you can take from
this workshop is three things one uh I
hope uh I makes I made sense of this
approach
So uh there is a GitHub repo uh which I
detailed it out and also a starter guide
on it one if you want to go home and try
with it you can you can try it. Uh you
already have know how the framework
works. So you want to go home and just
remix the whole approach you can do it
and let me also know uh I'll leave this
one and I'll join with you for
contribution. Uh you have a context gap
gap scanner that I showed you which is
live already with presets. Uh I think
like added like $20 on it. So hit it as
much as possible as well. 200 right?
Okay. Okay.
>> So after $20 so first serve.
Uh so all these three you can use uh you
can take away from this workshop.
Okay. So because this is a workshop so I
also would like to
want you to try something. Uh what you
can try is three things. One is either
uh if if you say like you know what I'm
so so tired already it's almost like 4
uh it's almost about to go for a party I
don't want to do it so you can just go
to the context gap scanner uh everything
is a preset here you can just try it out
hit it and see how it works if you think
it can be done better let me know so
that we can work together
uh
or otherwise uh let's say now I I'm very
technical. I want to know how it works
under the hood. Uh this is a GitHub
repository. Uh it's it's under uh maybe
I'll just take this out.
Uh this is a GitHub repository and it
has all the information. Uh plus there's
a starter guide also if you want to if
you want to try it out. But uh if you
still feel like no, I want much more
simpler
You can also try this one. So you don't
need to do anything. Basically take this
prompt uh take one of your Jira ticket
or incident that you have right now. If
you already built MCP servers uh or like
uh any other kind of a things, you just
use that uh prompt, give it to your
agent uh with the incident or a Jira
ticket and ask it uh give me the quality
of the knowledge base that I have as per
this incident or uh Jira ticket in this
way and see how many how much of it
comes in red which is never documented.
So you can you can try also the simple
one.
I'll just leave it like this. Maybe you
can take a picture. Maybe I can switch
to the slide if any anyone want to.
Cool.
>> This is your
>> So
this approach find it very interesting.
So first question is have you already
used this way of working at scale or
because we've seen most of the toy
examples right
>> y
>> uh I used it uh not at a scale uh I
started with simpler because you also
need to see what is the scope of it
let's say I have an enterprise and I try
an enterprise level I can't do it
because it's multiple domains things and
all even if I do it at domain level I
need to understand I tried it at a
domain level then even at a domain level
there is so much of a domain expertise I
need to fill it up and uh fill those
gaps. So again I cut down into maybe
what is the smallest team that I have
and the smallest teams Jira tickets the
smallest teams instance and the team's
confluence page uh with a bit of a scope
then if I drill down the scope then I
feel like it's more uh fast more useful
but if I do it at a bigger scope what
happens is not one person has the whole
uh domain expertise so basically it
again becomes like uh somebody has to
come and uh you know five or six people
has to sit down and start doing this
things.
>> Yeah, I'm a bit concerned that this
might denial of service attack your team
members in a certain way because our
LLMs are fine tuned to keep eliciting
information to keep getting more
information to ask follow
>> so I think it will be hard on the
engineers that have to do the question
answering
and secondly the scanner is nice but
still built on the assumption that all
of your team members and the rest of the
enterprise are still using your
enterprise it
>> well as planned that they're actually
filling in their tickets with all the
details etc and I know from practice
that is most of the time not the case
>> that is true that is true I agree with
you even if I go my my assumption is
also even if I go to a leadership to buy
in like hey can you give me a bandwidth
or like uh you know I need these people
to actually sit and fix the context. I
don't think right at this point of time
nobody will do but I think it will
happen because slowly I think we are
slowly moving towards an agent managers
where agents are becoming
semi-autonomous or autonomous and we
manage them but at the certain point of
time somebody has to fix that knowledge
because it's not going to come from
anywhere you have to so then the
enterprise focus will shift towards the
gap that's what I started saying I don't
think nobody is looking into the problem
Yet uh everybody is very focused with
agent how good the agent is, how good
the retrieval is but how good the
context is uh you're not solving it. I
think like in down the line in a year or
so I think people will realize
importance of it and uh the KBAN board
will definitely come into reality
actually very soon.
>> Yeah. Thanks.
>> I think actually the same point I think
when we look at large
search actually documentation actually
code. Just wondering have you applied it
to the code base?
>> Uh I did uh I also applied the code
base. Uh but I got a mixed result when I
uh so so here is the thing. What
happened is when I only use codebase uh
it is particularly good or when I only
use conflence or like textual data uh
like uh uh it gives a good results. But
when I combine it somehow actually uh it
conflicts because it it creates a theory
out of the GitHub repository but the
same GitHub repository documentation is
also on confluence.
So there it gets a conflict of okay what
is the source of truth to it code says
this should I implement it this way as
per the documentation. So then again I
need to create an additional skill or
rules like okay what is the ranking that
you need to give if you see it in GitHub
that means that is the source of truth
or if you see it if you don't see it
then you have to uh look the information
in confluence things and all but those
are still I'm trying to fix those things
actually so seeing the gaps and fix
those but I definitely see uh that issue
combining those two
>> and the second question is um
interestingly actually
skills because what we find out is
actually like you have your kind of like
your um like the process that's like run
a context and identify the right
>> then you do the task
identify
>> you go back
and then you're fixing the knowledge
back
Okay.
>> Uh I think right now the skill that I
have built is static but what you are
more proposing if I'm not wrong it's
like evolving skill right if the skill
fails it has to evolve right I agree
with you I never tried it but I think
like it has to be uh like that because
I'm also more concentrating on how to do
it at scale. uh the reason is also
uh I I want I want the context to be
fixed before retrieval itself
not during operational. So first when I
started with it I I started doing with
when operational which means oh I have a
work item I will assign to it it will
fail then I'll start giving context and
all but it takes a lot of time it takes
a lot of patience for me so rather than
doing it you know what I'm going to fix
the context but before retrieving so if
I can uh while I was answering her
question if you take a team the context
that you need to fix is very small so
you can use a uh context gap scanner uh
kind of a thing and maybe if you're good
have a good demoing expert I think like
couple of weeks you can actually fix
your documentation not like 100% at
least like 60 70 80% of a good quality
that you can already build it so my
proposal would always be don't do it at
an operational level uh at an real-time
level but do it before retrieval uh
itself that is much better in this
approach
>> y
especially
sitting in
situations where you ask questions that
may need I don't know like five or six
different
there
>> right now after cloud code announced 1
million of tokens in the context window.
I know I don't have any problem. So I
calculated it uh at an average it's like
uh 96k tokens because I tried with
different domains actually per domain I
see like around 96k tokens. uh if I
consolidate everything like confluence
things and all uh so easily fits in the
context window actually uh I tried to do
some experimentation around you know a
graph rag put them there rather than
just take all the files use a graph rag
understand the intent but for me just
putting the whole context right now in
the window gives you more results than
actually doing uh uh rack unless you
have a very big uh almost around a
million tokens of a context that you
want to fit in maybe then you have to
use a bit more uh retrieval mechanisms
between it but otherwise I think like uh
it should be fine.
>> I have a question uh I opened your paper
and could you explain this graph like
comparison between different techniques
like domain knowledge strategy knowledge
access uh
>> uh which one? Yep. Sure.
Okay. So, uh I also did the citations
from other papers. Okay. Uh so, not
directly related but u you have the
paper of ACE uh uh which is also does a
similar thing. So, uh but ACE is not
exactly into uh uh how do you say uh
discovery and curation actually uh if I
remember it correctly.
Maybe I need to refresh my memory.
>> What do you mean between uh the
difference between domain knowledge and
strategic knowledge here.
>> Okay. So strategic knowledge. Okay. So
what as and all uh are doing is when you
are trying to have a conversation with
uh AI uh you can see in the cloud code
and all it updates its uh memory or like
the relationship with your things like
that right. So and also from the chat
history it understands what is the most
important context I need to remember
those kind of a things. So when you are
in communication with it that
operational conversations with AI
improvement they propose. So what I my
proposal is not based upon your
conversation with an AI but rather than
your domain knowledge which is
documented actually.
>> Uh somebody else has a question.
>> Sorry.
When to remote knowledge so things are
confident
how do you ensure that your agent only
points to the
relevant documentation
in your local you have liked
>> okay so when I wrote a pipeline for
extracting from conflence it also allows
actually to give you a date and also
last updated who created kind of an
analytics on on the space. So you can
use it uh to actually put a threshold of
like okay on this particular date
whatever is is old consider it as an
outdated one and let me know. Don't just
consider it as an outdated one you let
me know because sometimes the document
can be stale for so long but it could be
an important document actually. So it
lets you know but not like take
decisions actually right now on this
one. So you decide uh which one is stale
and which one is not. you don't have
like an intermediate layer where in the
repo you store this is still
>> okay so uh when it is curated in the
context uh also it updates with a uh
date and also the state of the document
like stale active and clean so it also
looks into okay this is st I don't I'm
not going to touch it and I'll just go
to look for any other new other
documents are there uh in this one
>> you think about how to manage access
accessible.
>> Okay. So, because it's not a product or
a SAS solution, it's just basically
GitHub for me right now permissions and
things are not difficult to implement
because GitHub out of the box gives me
who I can give the permission to is
GitHub. who can have write read access
things and all who can merge those
things and all but in case if it evolves
into a product and for example context
gap scanner as a product and I want you
to test it because the the reason why I
was using presets for this uh workshop
not actually asking you to upload the
files is because I don't want to take
your IP data on this one right so unless
it becomes a product you don't have any
problem uh GitHub and all but if you
have a SAS solution for this
uh then it's between how the SAS
solution will manage it right right now
but the approach has nothing to do with
the access things and all how you
implement those access on on the
knowledge is up to you
>> you have so this is of course about
documentation but did you give any
consideration about using it on some
like central tooling that a company
would use like let's say that you have a
platform team and you have a CLI that
the different teams are using and so now
it's used by different agents right
>> okay
>> and so the agents can also be like well
this action is available for a resource
but I don't want to do 500 calls just
because I have a list of 500 resource
okay
>> it would be nice if the tool could do
that
I don't know if if you've given any
consideration to this
>> I think that is how it has to work uh in
an organization you need to have a
central solution for it but how you want
to do the solution is up to the
organization for example we are doing
agile right So agile can do by scrum
kban or like lean or something and also
you can do different apps to do it. The
the process is the same but how you do
it which method you will choose and
which app will you choose in your
organization is different. In the same
way what we have discussed is the
approach. If you want to put it in the
organization you can use the approach
and you do you can do it in whichever
way you want. My point is more like so
with this you can identify gaps in your
>> right could you use it to identify gaps
on your tooling for
>> okay uh when you say tooling it's the
agentic
>> internal tools that I don't know maybe a
team is building for the rest of the
company
>> infrastructure in general right
>> maybe yeah
>> uh can you give me an example of uh like
uh how
>> let's say that uh I don't know you build
some sort of abstraction on top of
kubernetes
>> okay
>> you don't want your developers to
necessarily know what to do with that.
Okay.
>> Then you have a different CLI or you
have something right.
>> Um but then like I say I don't know
maybe you thought that they would
release one of your custom applications
or corporate applications one by one
>> but a team has grown into using more of
that and suddenly they have a lot and
they don't want to do that many calls or
>> perhaps even the agent is like well this
is inefficient. I would like this
internal tool to work in a different
way.
>> Okay. And in that way you would identify
like gap in the tool or a performance
improvement kind of like this does for
documentation
>> could be extended actually.
>> So uh because uh we have seen the
business processes also right. So it can
also document business process. The
business process is nothing but how uh
the process in the application it
actually runs and does things right. So
you can extend it to also find out the
gaps in the business process or like how
it works. It could be an extinction to
it.
>> Sorry.
>> How would you ensure that
you know
changes?
>> Yeah. The answer for question is
tomorrow
on Friday
to identify B1 and B and over
text that's problem.
>> Okay. So uh when I showed the context
gap scanner you also saw like an
indicator of duplication right? So if
today you have a document tomorrow you
have version 2.0 zero and something else
actually it will find out the same
information is having in three different
it it will also will find it. If you
have only one it is changed it will take
the latest updated one because as a
human you changed it so it will take it
as a source of truth right but if you
have three versions of the same document
that's a duplication and it will flag it
as a duplicate
>> right but it's a s how do you ensure
the performance Let's say document of
100,000 words
>> just change a word like let's say there
for example right has changed
>> okay
>> so you have to find
compare those three documents
tools you use to ensure
>> uh Um I didn't quite get your question
actually. Uh is it like the token usage
you're worried about like uh the that
many tokens that we used how how is what
is the costsaving? Yeah, precisely
changes
maintain maintain that whole database
right
>> I don't know
whatever right
my question is well because what you
presented is sort of a happy path where
you have a cup it and then you reuse it
>> but in a while you will have a where you
pretend to have that gap
but actually it doesn't contain up to
date information
contains wrong information. So you want
to preserve that.
>> Ah okay. Okay. Uh so it can flag as per
when it is created or last updated. You
can set such kind of a filters. But
let's say you have a latest document
which has a wrong information.
>> Right. know that right?
>> No that's true. uh but as for example as
a human being right so you go and look
into documentation you told somebody to
look into documentation and the person
looked into the documentation and as per
the documentation this is be implemented
in this way the person will do it right
it's not an agent or a human issue
>> too late I mean you solved one
>> and the agent is trying to assume
>> so it's solving it but the solution is
wrong
Okay.
>> So you say there is a scanner fine. Do
you run it daily? How much will it cost?
>> You you can have another process spot
that would try to see like last updated
>> uh try to see on some cadence try to run
a process that will update the
knowledge.
>> Fantastic. How much will it cost?
>> Uh for for example uh sorry you're
saying
>> less than than doing more meetings uh
every day to onboard someone or
That's a strong claim
>> but I don't think it will cost that much
as
>> premise of AI.
>> Yep. As I said like uh when I tested it
there is none of the domains which cross
more than 100k tokens actually. So I
don't think we will for example contact
gap scanner right you I don't think like
you have to do it like on a daily basis
or anything even if you run daily basis
like 100 tokens and do one scan for
example right if you try to start
hitting all of them uh all of you the
context cap scanner I think you can't
even burn like one $1 I think so if I'm
not wrong it already had like oh you're
ready okay uh okay I'll I'll cancel the
subscription now
But I
>> go back and defend two things. One is a
compository
system documentation for so I agree with
you.
So scale you would have to solve this
question.
>> Okay. which is going to be depend also
how fast the
how fast the the data change I think not
that much you get to like 80%
>> yeah use case by use case yeah any other
questions
>> okay
>> how do I know that's
uh
>> it it
>> it actually tries to detail out as much
as possible. Right now I haven't
actually exposed everything what it did
just for the UI purpose. Uh but the all
the per ticket what it actually found
like uh it writes like a 100 or like 150
lines of uh markdown files and save it
somewhere. So that gives you more
details in case if you want to know
actually. So for for the demo I just put
the you know nice UX stuff on on top of
it but you also have a detailed
information at uh test.
>> Anyone else has any questions?
>> Can I have one?
>> Yeah, sure. Go on.
>> Right.
>> Easy one. Huh?
I destroy
>> if I translation right your claim is
>> not
>> not fill the gaps uh but discover but if
you scope down to a team within weeks
you can do
I mean if you wouldn't feel it and keep
asking those questions then make sense
right so at some point you have another
value
>> yeah so you do it one time first of all
or like multiple times at first see the
whole picture first of all what is the
state of your knowledge base first fix
it uh at that level then you go into
operations right you still can actually
uh also
you you can still continue doing it with
the agent with skills.
>> Yep.
>> And
I think the same process of kind of
providing that knowledge is
>> happens pretty frequently when a new
member joins
>> the organization. So
>> wouldn't a replacement that be just Zoom
calls, transfer them and use them as
source. Assuming all the calls or all
the knowledge transfers or maybe
introductions happen
>> or team or whatever the
new member join asking questions and you
have access to that.
>> Okay. So you mean like you can also give
all the transcripts rather than uh uh
doing the cycle you mean uh that can
also be done uh if you're only have the
all the time you have discussions in
everything is documented meetings
transcript itself but I don't think like
that's the same case for everyone at
least uh
>> but easier
that I don't know I'm unsure
I think the amount of time people
spending in teams if you do use the
transcripts actually those are the ones
actually who which uh have more tokens
actually there are so many useless
meetings uh the transcripts actually
>> totally agree but compression only one
and then part of the database
>> could be again it depends upon
institution to institution right so are
you like more into meetings, have
solving problems within the
conversations and those conversations
has the data or like your conflence or
things has the data. If you have it, use
that those transcripts as your knowledge
base and at the same time like the
compression actually that works actually
that that is more useful. Yeah.
Anyone else? Any questions? No. All
good.
Uh then uh thank you so much uh for
attending this session.